Transcriber: Carol Matouk
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
ريان الشمري
الفكرة التي أود التكلم عنها اليوم
أتمنى أن تصل إلى النازحين والأسر المتعففة.
والمنظمات المحلية أو الدولية، حيث ستساهم
بشكل إيجابي في التخفيف من المعاناة
التي نعيشها في محافظة تعز.
السلام عليكم.
كان هناك شاب مسافر من مدينة
تعز إلى مدينة المكلا.
وصل المكلا فاتصلت به والدته
ألو، كيف حالك يا ابني؟
أنا من دون طعامٍ منذ الصباح.
تخيلوا! أنا من دون طعام منذ الصباح.
لماذا يا أمي؟
قالت له: اسطوانة الغاز نفذت.
وتبين أن الأسطوانة الاحتياطية تسرّب الغاز.
لا يوجد لدي غاز
ولا يوجد أحد يعطيني أو يحضر لي الغاز.
ماذا فعل الشاب هنا؟
فكر قليلاً ثم اتصل بابن عمه.
قلت له: لو سمحت يا لؤي
اذهب واجلب الغاز إلى المنزل.
فذهب ليبحث عن غاز
ولكن لم يتمكن من إيجاده.
مرة ثانية، حاول أن يستخدم علاقاته
واتصل بأحد أصدقائه.
لو سمحت يا فلان
هل يمكن أن تؤمن لي اسطوانة؟
فقال له: لا مشكلة.
أحضر الأسطوانة الفارغة
وسأبدلها لك بواحدة ممتلئة.
الحمد لله، استطاع أن يتجاوز هذه المشكلة.
ولم يضطر أن يعود أو يقطع
مسافة تزيد عن 500 كيلومتر من حضرموت
المكلا إلى تعز كي يوفر لأمه اسطوانة غاز.
هذا الشاب يا سادة هو أنا.
هذه كانت أمي، وهذه كانت معاناتي
في انعدام مادة الغاز المنزلي.
صراحةً، لا أخفيكم
أن هذه الفكرة هذه أزعجتنا كثيرًا.
وأنا معتاد دائماً عندما أسافر
أن أوفر لوالدتي كل احتياجاتها
من أكل وشرب غاز وغيره
لكن هذه المرة لم أكن
أتوقع هذا الشيء.
بدأت أبحث وأفكر
عن طريقة يمكنني فيها
أن أساعد نفسي والآخرين.
كيف يمكن أن يتوافر بديل
لأي شخص عندما ينفذ الغاز لديه؟
ليستخدمه في حال انعدام الغاز
أو ارتفاع سعره.
أو في حال لم يكن هناك غاز في المدينة.
لا أخفيكم أنني أمضيت ثلاثة أشهر
في البحث والقراءة ولكن
الحظ لم يحالفني.
وفي يوم من الأيام في شهر أغسطس
تواصلت أنا وأحد الأصدقاء.
وقال لي: يا ريان، هناك دورة تدريبية
في صناعة الطباخ الشمسي.
طباخ شمسي؟! ما هو الطباخ الشمسي؟
للصراحة أنني ذُهلت.
ذُهلت كثيراً بالطباخ الشمسي.
ما هي فكرته؟
وما الذي يمكننا فعله بالطباخ الشمسي؟
قلت له: حسناً
يمكنك أن تسجلني لا مشكلة أبداً.
والحمد لله تم تسجيلي.
وحصلت على هذا التدريب.
وباختصار يا سادة..
الطباخ الشمسي..
كما تشاهدون، هذا هو الطباخ الشمسي
فكرته بسيطة جداً.
آلية عمله بسيطة جداً
وسنتعرف عليها اليوم، إن شاء الله.
أولاً، الطباخ الشمسي
ما هو مفهومه وتعريفه وفكرته؟
هو آلة أو جهاز أو أداة لصنع الطعام
أو تسخينه
أو تعقيم بعض المواد الطبية.
هو يستخدم أيضاً كمعقم للمواد الطبية.
ما هي فكرة الطباخ الشمسي؟
فكرة الطباخ الشمسي بسيطة جداً.
تسقط أشعة الشمس على النافذة الزجاجية
وبالتالي، تمتصها الأسطح الداكنة
داخل الطباخ نفسه.
وتعمل على عملية تسخين الهواء
داخل الطباخ أو داخل الفرن.
وهو الذي يعمل على عملية طهو الطعام.
هذه فكرة الطباخ الشمسي باختصار شديد.
الطباخ الشمسي له مميزاته.
وأبرز مميزاته تكمن في كونه صديقاً للبيئة.
ماذا نعني بصديق للبيئة؟
هذا يعني أنه لا يحتاج لأي وقود.
لا يحتاج غاز أو كهرباء أو بترول
ولا يحتاج كاز ولا أي مصدر من مصادر الوقود.
وأيضاً، يمكننا أن نقول
أنه بسيطة من ناحية التكلفة.
تكلفته مقبولة نوعاً ما.
60 دولار ولكن إن قمنا بمقارنتها باستدامته.
تخيل معي، يمكن أن يدوم لمدة خمس سنوات
من دون أي مصدر من مصادر الوقود
لذلك يكون حلاً مناسباً جداً
للأسر داخل مدينة تعز أو خارجها
وأيضاً من مميزات الطباخ الشمسي
أو الفرن الشمسي
من مميزاته
أنه خفيف الوزن، ويمكن نقله إلى أي مكان،
وهو أيضاً يناسب العديد من أنواع الأطعمة،
مخبوزات أو معجنات
كيك، كعك، يناسبها جميعاً.
أرز، زربيان، دجاج
لحم، بطاطس، مناسب لها جداً
لا أخفيكم.
عندما نقوم بطرح أي مشروع أو أي فكرة
فلا بد من موجود معوقات
أو تحديات تحد من وصول هذه الفكرة.
أبرز التحديات التي واجهتني
أثناء طرحي لهذه الفكرة،
كانت افتراض عدم عمل هذا الطباخ.
الكثير من الناس كانوا يقولون لي:
هذا الطباخ غير نافع، أو غير عملي.
فماذا فعلت أنا؟
كنت أقوم بتجارب ومن ثم أنشرها،
كنت أعد فيه طعاماً
ومن ثم أقوم بنشره، وبالتالي
انخفض هذا المعوق أو هذا التحدي كثيراً.
التحدي الثاني.
الأسر التي لا تمتلك مصدراً..
أعني ليس لديها شرفة أو سطح
أو حديقة يمكنها أن تضع فيه الطباخ وتستخدمه
ونحن نعمل الآن على هذه الفكرة،
بحيث نحاول مساعدة هؤلاء الناس
بالاستخدام الأمثل للطباخ الشمسي،
حيث نعمل بالتعاون مع طلاب من جامعة تعز
من قسم الميكاترونيكس في كلية الهندسة،
على تصنيع جهاز
يمكن وصله بالصندوق أو بالطباخ الشمسي،
وهو يعمل على عملية وصل الطباخ
باللوح الشمسي مباشرة،
بحيث يستخدم في عملية تحضير الطعام.
حسناً، الطباخ موجود
في اليمن؟ كلا
موجود في منطقة أخرى، ليس في اليمن فقط،
في منطقة تسمى "صحراء أتاكاما"
هل سمع أحد بـ "صحراء أتاكاما" من قبل؟
“صحراء أتاكاما” يا سادة
تقع في “تشيلي” في أمريكا الجنوبية،
مساحتها 105 ألف كيلومتر مربع
مئة وخمسة الاف كيلو متر مربع.
،هذه الصحراء تعتبر منطقة جذب سياحية
يأتيها السياح من جميع أنحاء العالم.
تضاريسها أشبه كما لو كنت
في المريخ وليس على الأرض.
ما الذي يميز هذه الصحراء؟
يوجد مطعم في هذه الصحراء،
وهذا المطعم
يستخدم الطباخ الشمسي في إعداد الأطعمة.
بالطبع هذه المنطقة تتميز بعدم وجود
مصادر للوقود فيها، كما يمكننا القول
لا توجد فيها أمطارٌ حتى
لا يوجد فيها أمطار نهائياً،
وهذا بسبب وقوعها على أعلى هضبة في العالم،
وبالتالي الجبال التي
تحد هذه الصحراء، تعمل على
كما يمكننا القول، على عدم تشكيل الغيوم
فوق هذه المنطقة
وبالتالي لا يوجد فيها أمطار
ولا يوجد فيها كهرباء
أو غاز أو أي مصدر للوقود،
وبالتالي يستخدمون الطباخ الشمسي
لتحضير الأطعمة،
وهذا ما يميز الصحراء
وزاد من الإقبال عليها.
الطباخ الشمسي لا يقتصر على هذه الأماكن،
ولكن يمكن تطبيقه
في اليمن وفي أماكن أخرى أيضاً.
حسناً يا ريان، الطباخ موجود
والجميع قادرين على استخدامه
ما الجديد في الأمر؟
الجديد يا سادة وبكل فخر
أنني عملت، ولغاية وقوفي أمامكم الآن
على تدريب ما يزيد عن 53 شاب وشابة
على صناعة واستخدام الطباخ الشمسي.
ولحد الآن.
صنعت ما يزيد عن 19 طباخ شمسي
19 طباخ شمسي، يتم استخدامها في مدينة تعز.
قد يرى البعض أنه عدد قليل
ولكنني لا أراه قليلاً
خلال شهرين أو منذ إطلاق مبادرتي قبل شهرين.
حسناً، ما الذي تطمح له؟
ما أطمح له
هو أن يتواجد هذا الطباخ في كل منزل،
أو في كل خيمة نازحين في مدينة تعز.
أنتم تعرفون عدد النازحين
في الجمهورية بشكل عام.
عدد النازحين في الجمهورية بشكل عام
وفقاً لمكتب تنسيق الشؤون الإنسانية ،OCHA
في عام 2021  ما يزيد عن
4 مليون نازح ونازحة.
وأغلبهم من النساء والأطفال،
وهؤلاء النساء والأطفال
هم المعنيين بتوفير الأحطاب والوقود،
لتحضير الأطعمة.
هم من يجمعون الكرتون
الأطفال يقومون بجمع الكرتون،
والنساء هن من يجمعن الأحطاب.
وبالتالي، إن استطعنا
أن نوفر هذا الصندوق أو هذا الفرن الشمسي
لكل أسرة نازحة أو محتاجة داخل مدينة تعز،
فنخفف من هذه المعاناة بشكلٍ كبير
ونساهم أيضاً في حماية البيئة
والتقليل من التصحر.
وهذا ما أطمح إليه
في المشروع الذي سنبدأ به
في عام 2022 إن شاء الله
والذي سيكون عبارة عن فتح ورشة خيرية لصناعة
واستخدام الطباخ الشمسي،
وتدريب المتطوعين والمتطوعات عليه
من خلال توفير مواد لصناعة الطباخ،
وتدريب هؤلاء الأشخاص
على صناعة الطباخ الشمسي
ومن ثم بيعها سواءً للأسر المتعففة
أو لمنظمات المجتمع المدني
أو لفاعلي وفاعلات خير،
وبسعر التكلفة
بسعر التكلفة،
لن يكون هناك أي هامش ربح.
وبعد ذلك، هذه التكلفة
أو هذه العائدات من بيع هذه الطباخات
نأخذها ونشتري فيها مواد جديدة
ونستخدمها أيضاً في عملية
تدريب متطوعين ومتطوعات آخرين،
وهذا إن شاء الله ما سنقوم به في عام 2022.
أتمنى منكم، أن تنشروا هذا الموضوع،
أتمنى أن نصنع البركة لمجتمعنا.
وشكراً جزيلاً لكم.
(تصفيق)